all right tonight liberal literacy is
spiraling out of control on both coasts
now listen to this New York City's
government they agreed to pay over
twenty thousand dollars each to hundreds
of protesters from the 2020 riots
because they were either confined or
they claimed they were beaten by the
police now the total bill comes in at
more than six million dollars protesters
and by the way they used a New York City
police van on fire to entice people to
come to that what ended up being quote
called arrived by some but that's not
all New York City get this only in New
York City they are going to buy five
outside public toilets
they are paying
5.3 million dollars to install five
toilets across the five boroughs now
that costs less than what a million
dollars to buy uh it's all due to the
bureaucratic red tape big government
spending regulations and by the way it's
no better on the west coast Oregon is
now considering a bill to pay homeless
people one thousand dollars every month
simply for being homeless you can't make
this up here now outkick founder clay
Travis former New York City mayoral
candidate boy this city would be so much
better off if he had one
Curtis Sliwa
now mayor Adams appointed you the rats
are you still the rats are uh no he
fired me within three days said no pay
because I was actually getting stuff
done in front of his building it was
embarrassing to him how can you deal
with rats in the city if you can't even
deal with the rats in your own building
that's a great question all right let's
let's talk about the insanity of these
New York policies here you're paying
protesters they use this this image of a
New York City Police Department van
Ablaze to entice people to go to this
event they had a curfew in place they
police enforced the curfew and now every
one of those protesters gets 21 500
bucks are you kidding me it's black
lives matter Lotto anti-folado it's
incredible remember on this very Network
Hawk Newson head of black lives matter
said we're gonna burn this mother down
right and that was in the Bronx and
that's exactly where these demonstrators
were attacking cops throwing Molotov
cocktails cops getting barrage having to
go to the hospital imagine you get a
Payday of 21 000. you remember Sean I
was battling antifa black lives matter
they broke my jaw that's why you have
those pictures with me with that beard
remember to act as a protection what did
I get I got regards I got bump keys and
I tell you what this is just symptomatic
of the city you go out there you burn
Loot and shoot and we give you money the
only way you actually make more money
sneak down to Mexico come across the
border come up to New York we put you in
a five-star top shelf hotel we give you
champagne and Cocktails and caviar all
the taxpayers expense four billion
dollars can't beat that four million
dollars Sean
this is why he should have been elected
all right let me bring in clay Travis
Clay uh a thousand dollars a month to be
homeless
um how how are they going to afford that
and how many people will be taking
advantage of that
the whole statement look all of these
left-wing policies I appreciate Curtis
there they're all broken right and and
what is happening is if you look at
California you look at New York what are
people saying I can stay where I am and
pay 12 or 13 state income tax or guess
what the great state of Tennessee where
I am right now or Florida or Texas zero
percent state income tax so what
happened with kovid Sean red got redder
blue got Bluer and a lot of people who
do have the ability to leave have said
I'm fed up I'm not fighting these
battles anymore I'm gonna leave behind
all this left-wing insanity and I'm
gonna go to a sane red state where I got
a zero percentage
and I really think that it's changing
everything there's going to be five
public toilets a million in New York you
will not be able to use either one any
one of them not one
you can rent I used to be in
construction you can rent a porta potty
for a month and it's only a few hundred
dollars a month it's not that expensive
yeah but I got to tell you Sean what do
you think Jesus Saddam Hussein
gold-plated porcelain balances remember
how he had one at every Palace and it's
only two hundred thousand dollars eight
hundred thousand to install I know that
means you have no show jobs feather
feathers you hold the ranch I want to
tell you right now what's going to
happen is the drug addicts are going to
use it they're going to shoot up in it
the homeless people they're going to
squat in it you'll never get them out
put up a Hibachi Grill in there right
and bring all
last word the world has gone nuts we
need to look I wish we need to be out
there
everywhere you can't go anywhere
thank you
I think I think we're better off we if
we move with would you ever move out of
New York no improve don't move we fight
for what we know is right we're not
giving up our city I'll miss you you see
I'm taking on AOC right and that story
is set up to Ronald Reagan Republican
Club right to visit me when I moved to a
no income tax state Sean please please
okay I want you to come into the subway
with me again for all times sometimes
say I will do that all right hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else